les plus influentes de France aux vidéos
ont été vues
258 millions de fois
[Applaudissements]
et vous êtes ici ce soir
parce que je voulais que vous voyez les
gens vous êtes en train de mettre au
chômage avec vos conneries alors d'un
tout vous êtes la youtubeuse star
actuellement
2,5 millions d'abonnés sur Youtube vos
vidéos ont été vues 258 millions de fois
c'est vrai alors les adolescents vous
adorent selon un sondage sur les 12 18
vous êtes plus populaire que la
masturbation
vous êtes ici ce soir comment visite un
musée voilà comment c'était avant
youtube
il y avait des plateaux il y avait un
public et des musiciens
[Applaudissements]
alors
vous ne regardez plus la télévision
ça m'arrive de le laisser en fond sonore
des fois pour avoir une petite compagnie
comme les vieux
alors vous êtes passé dans On n'est pas
couché l'émission de Laurent Ruquier
j'ai eu le sentiment d'être en face de
gens qui n'y connaissent rien c'est
comme un repas de famille chez ma tante
quoi
à mon avis il vous a confondu avec
Jean-Luc Lahaye
déjà c'était très ennuyeux j'ai passé
trois heures assis sur ma chaise avant
de passer mais c'est vrai que je me suis
retrouvé face à des gens qui avaient pas
du tout bossé leur sujet et je trouvais
ça étonnant que Léa Salamé soit aussi
déphasé sur ce sujet alors qu'elle a que
50 plus que moi on est beaucoup plus
moderne
c'est très drôle moi j'adore
vraiment vous êtes excellentes moi je me
marque comme avec le Palmashow quand je
regarde vos vidéos merci c'est un
compliment c'est des vidéos qui font 10
12 millions de vues attention c'est pas
une manif de la CGT la Pierrot
alors vous regardez pas la télé mais
vous publiez un livre et quand vous
publiez un livre vous venez faire la
promotion la télé quand même c'est mon
éditeur qui me pousse alors le livre
s'appelle
icône c'est publié chez Michel Lafont je
ne parodie de magazine féminin avec des
faux articles des fausses pubs des faux
jeux vous en voulez vraiment la presse
féminine parce que vous les accusez de
toujours montrer en fait finalement la
même femme stéréotype quoi oui
je lui en veux pas vraiment parce que
c'est vraiment une lecture que je
consomme quand je suis à la plage ou
dans dans le train ça m'amuse mais il y
a des choses qui m'agacent c'est vrai
que par exemple tous les conseils sur
les régimes et quand on a pas derrière
on nous dit bah assumez vous tel que
vous êtes et on retourne la page on a un
tube de crème pour la cellulite et il y
a plein de petites choses comme ça
agaçantes comme les crèmes anti-rides ou
c'est des nanas en fait qui ont 20 ans
qui font la pub c'est assez abérant et
maintenant c'est vrai que grâce à
YouTube en tout cas il y a plus de
filles qui se lancent qui correspondent
pas forcément aux critères de beauté
classique que la société nous impose et
je pense qu'on va peut-être avoir une
phase de transition il y a de plus en
plus vous aurez fait beaucoup pour les
femmes
alors
il faut savoir
c'est que
a déjà vendu 225
000 exemplaires de son livre ça laisse
rêveur
pierre il en est pas là
alors vous regardez pas la télé mais la
télé parle de vous et quand la télé
parle de vous vous mettez les photos sur
sur Instagram quel métier exercer Natoo
avant d'être la youtubeuse et
l'humoriste que l'on connaît réponse
flics
[Musique]
rien et oui vous étiez au commissariat
de Draveil et des Vigneux-sur-Seine
j'étais une flic assez cool et je pense
que rapidement je me suis rendu compte
que c'était pas ma place moi je suis
vraiment entendre la police avec une
vision assez
utopique
quand le méchant arrache le sac à la
grand-mère et moi je tombe à pic et
j'arrive
dans un Picard
dans un Picard et donc Natoo est dehors
elle fait son stage et d'un seul coup le
mec sort du picard en courant elle le
plaque j'essaie de le ceinturer mais
j'ai ceinturé en dessous des bras donc
il m'a mis une grosse patate du coup il
est tombé il s'est fait très mal au
genou
voilà alors c'est vrai que cet épisode
dans la police vous dites enrouler avec
des voitures sans phares et on mettait
des amandes à des gens qui n'avaient pas
de phare non plus
après un moment vous en avez marre de
tout ça vous mettez à faire des vidéos
on connaît la suite et maintenant on a
tout quand vous mettez des menottes à
quelqu'un c'est pour le plaisir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu